- [Kelly] But your CODA
co-star Daniel Durant
competed in Dancing With the Stars.
So, that was last season.
Did you ever get a chance to go watch him?
- [Interpreter] I absolutely did.
I was there, me and Troy Kotsur,
we were like the proud
onscreen parents for Daniel,
visiting our son on
Dancing With the Stars.
And we rooted him on and
he is such a great dancer.
He's in a different place here, you know,
watching him dance as opposed to acting.
Totally outside of the box.
We were so proud of him.
- Do you like dancing?
I love dancing.
- [Interpreter] I like dancing, but
I don't know about being in
front of 25 million people
and then having them
vote for me about that.
I don't know if I like that.
(audience laughing)
- No, no, no.
I just meant dancing in general.
I think it feels so good.
- [Marlee] Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yes.
- Yeah.
- I love to dance anytime,
anywhere, anybody.
- Oh, it felt so- you don't,
she didn't even have a bar, anybody.
That's amazing.
(Kelly and Marlee laughing)